So how do we apply this to clustering,
okay?
Well, basically the idea is you,
you're going to clust together
all the data points that are in
an attraction basin of one mode.
So, what's an attraction basin?
An attraction basin is the region for
which all the trajectories lead to
the same mode, or
all the points go there, all right?
So here's a very simple example.
So here is a set of points,
drawn from a distribution.
And you can tell, obviously that,
the idea is that there probably is
a mode here, and theres a mode there.
Great, the question is,
which points belong to which mode?
And that's done very simply by,
if you were to start your mean shift
in each of these locations,
which mode does it end up at?
All right, and that's illustrated
in this figure here, right?
So, here we're showing
you the area of which
all of the, the mean shifts get to
this mode, the mode on the right.
Likewise, everywhere over here,
they get to the mode on the left.
So it clusters your feature space
using these basins of attraction
to the two modes, all right?
So, when we're going to do this for
segmenting a color image, what we
have to do is define some feature.
So maybe we're using just u and
v or maybe u, v, and x, y,
if we want a color and location.
We have to initialize the window,
the windows at every pixel,
that is every possible color
point in that LUV space.
Now, would you do every one?
No, you would take a sampling of them.
You do mean shift until it converges.
And then you merge all the pixels,
all those initial points into
a single cluster that all end
up at the same peak, all right?
And so, that looks a little
bit like this, all right?
So here, L and U, this is L and V, okay?
These are the actual pixel colors,
distributed.
And if you run your clustering,
and here, it's being done in this,
LU space, all right?
If you run your mean shift here,
okay, you will see,
see all these points going
up to that peak right there?
And then there's a peak here,
and a peak here, and a peak here?
Those, let's see, one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
so there's seven modes here, and that
means there seven basins of attraction,
which means you would end up
with seven regions in the image.